[Music]
and can't do it new
I can't burn away submitted by Marlin
decor key all I like the cause is a
vegetarian cattle farmer who couldn't
kill his cows donated them to an animal
sanctuary why was he trying to kill his
club why was he farming the cattle yeah
people know he inherited this farm to
water that's all for me his dad died
back in toast
2011 oh my god that's so funny oh my god
what you want here right now brother in
a song yeah why is it so funny
the irony is just but he's a vegetarian
and he inherited if I can cattle farm
that's like Oh civil rights activists
that inherited the position of the king
of the KKK this 59 year old man his name
is Jay he's from the UK he's been a
vegetarian for the past 25 years
well that's a dedication but he eats
eggs though that's a vegetarian yeah
vegetarian he's a vegan oh I love eggs
man I love eggs - scrambled a spam and
rice and some kimchi over easy
over medium for me get him something
poached and I can't and so he was just
saying that I want cows like he couldn't
so did family a farm they would raise
these cows to be sent to the
slaughterhouse and he said he just
couldn't bear to do that my mouth is
watering right now is that bad that's
normal watering because you want to eat
them or welcome why I'm just asking
she's ended a question she's crazy
okay no course don't [ __ ] up of course
the sucks there Katie girls groups but
is it sexual or is it for the food for
the food you couldn't do it for the
dairy either because it really broke his
heart having this separate the mom from
two babies and so that's why he's just
saying that you know what even though I
can get a lot of money out of these cows
for selling them event he's like I can't
do that I can't see these cows being
sent to go get killed or be used for
their body so he ended up sending them
off
an animal sanctuary why didn't he just
leave them on his phone oh because he's
going to start he's going to convert a
new farm into like a vegan party always
going to have crops to know what you
should and he has Pokemon buildings and
on his property that aren't being used
for anything so he wants to create those
into restaurants and have like and kind
of like a vegan experience so now
they're saying sure he's going to kill
all these cows and make steaks and
they're gonna have a big-ass barbecue
sanctuaries don't normally kill them I
know they love say all I know is that
[ __ ] cows produce a lot of poop and
along happen and magic mushrooms grow on
that [ __ ] so you could get high as a
[ __ ] drives on the king I kind
of understand this guy but if I was him
I'd be really [ __ ] sad while I'm
eating my cow and I wouldn't be able to
give the cow away like I I wouldn't care
about the money it's like I don't give a
[ __ ] how much money I could make per
steer because I raised this [ __ ] I'm
eating this [ __ ] it's my food then you
said you're not going to eat that you
can't eat it then no no I'm gonna this
is what's going to happen I'm going to
inherit the farm I'm not a vegetarian as
meat
I'm going to [ __ ] get greedy and say
like I spent a lot of time growing these
guys if anyone's going to eat them it's
going to be me and my friends but then
while I'm barbecuing I'm going to be
really sad because all the memories so
you're not going to stop we're just
going to keep eating them while I'm fat
I'll be depressed as [ __ ] but I'll be
really really full you like Homer
Simpson job what is lobster so how you
crying it's like the brisket balls
sweet ha ok thing like he sees these
like his cattle will be born and grow up
their attachment to him he has crazy
attachments it could be said that cows
they have individual personalities they
have feelings that he he swear that he
has seen cows cry and smile and like
theythey change their expression chosen
animals are going to have feelings
he's anthropomorphic deities
have friends who don't live in don't
live in California they live wood in
this Pennsylvania Pennsylvania with like
hot adds like a [ __ ] ton of acres of
land and they have goats chickens a
whole bunch of [ __ ] and they became
vegan because they're like they're like
the act just like dogs like everything
one of these animals that they're no
different than at all the other day no I
under percent believe that like we we
choose which animals we think are edible
or not based on our affection towards
them or what we think is cute however
for me I'm I think you would become
vegetarian I don't think I'd become
vegetarian to the Taliban and you had a
farm and and hunt and do all that when I
was a kid I used to go to Korea and I
watched like animal slaughtered in front
of me I've seen chickens killed in front
of me and I still ate it so for me it's
not because I was exposed to that as a
kid and I understand what it's like but
you like see from the most so maybe that
affected why you don't like any other
flavor though yeah I even like the taste
of beef so even today I don't like beef
that much but I will crave a steak every
now and then but for me I could go my
whole life not eating pork or beef and
I'll be 100% fine if you take like
seafood away from me I might have a
problem today was saying that these
animals they are alive and they're
living and have their own experience
they're alive and they're living in
resent having their own unique
experience on this world and for him he
just doesn't feel right sending them off
to get started because he's like I'm
sure 100% they they can feel here that's
why I gotta kill em fast you can't kill
them slow that's [ __ ] up that's
inhumane that's really nice of them to
think like that though I wish I could
think like that but rib eyes are too
delicious you need me to drive all right
I love red meat I go to the aquarium and
I see the schools of fish like going
around I'm like that's [ __ ] beautiful
I experienced that one and I felt so
weird that isn't where that's actually
normal though because where were the
pretty much the top predator you know we
eat everything I don't have a problem
with people right eating me yeah I mean
I have a problem with people wasting
food and eating in an excess you know
like that's that's my biggest issue like
if you have a stop if your fridge is
[ __ ] stocked full and you're still
going out to eat every day that's the
[ __ ] issue
because that food should be eaten first
you know so a majority of the stuff that
can be stopped isn't like so much in the
sense of it's like supplying them in you
know I mean so if people keep on buying
[ __ ] in excess and throwing it away we
can't fix any [ __ ] that's true I don't
like it when a whole cow has to give its
life away and then it's like yeah it's
like you only took the one little piece
it's like imagine if you just got the
cow tongue and you kill the whole cow
just left that's a weight even how we do
Agriculture's all [ __ ] up too and how
we like water our [ __ ] that's why
America is awesome because like you know
you'll have the white people that eat
all the steaks and then you have the
Chinese people that will eat the
eyeballs and all the other [ __ ] so like
you know just bring it all together
because if a cow was slaughtered out in
China it's like no one theme the brisket
no one's eating the steak no one's
eating that they just want the [ __ ]
cow anus and the next can eat the tongue
oh yeah I don't think I've ever seen a
Chinese dish with Tom oh there are a
song to have I'll like it it's like and
that might call it Fox hunger central
it'll do it as good as Mexicans yeah
they were talking on you know what could
they leave the [ __ ] taste buds on
that [ __ ] yeah I got it at a Chinese
cafe and it was like [ __ ] ox tongue
[ __ ] stew or some [ __ ] take the skin
off this yes oh I thought it was going
to be small slices right it was just a
tongue yeah that was diced up yeah with
[ __ ] there's tongue pores on that
[ __ ] taste buds and then the sauce may
have is like this bell pepper sauce and
onions yeah I'm sitting there chewing it
like bubblegum like yeah it's not [ __ ]
dude Mexican people know how to cook
tongue like a [ __ ]
lengua I like homestyle cooking like
that too because in home style cooking
is not so much about the aesthetics is
about using everything that's available
so that's why you see like stews you see
like tacos it's just chopped up but it's
put in you have everything but you have
a lot of these like modern restaurants
where they plate something they take a
carrot they chop it up with these
purpose squares and where does the
scraps go right into the bin doesn't
look good they throw it right in the bit
it's because they're so rich they don't
care so these carrot trimmings nobody
needs them that's why I like you might
say like my favorite restaurants in LA
or always like these homestyle places
could we get out take me to the most
ghettoest place
the stems on the vegetables presentation
is horrible that's how you know they
don't waste but good for this guy he
said he has a big heart but at the same
time those cows are going to die one day
well they're gonna die of natural causes
at this point because now they're gonna
be living in a sanctuary you know
they're one of the main causes of
[ __ ] ozone layers opening because
they fart so damn much so he did end up
keeping 11 of his cows that's not in
order to I just keep on my pet and then
you're going to be using the manure from
these cows in order to use it as a
natural fertilizer for his vegetable
farms that one is beautiful home
I want a pet of Khaled a probably baby
calves the little [ __ ] baby was a
hella cute dude I think anything baby is
cute baby porcupines baby alligators
Gigi
baby far I feel one time and I didn't
understand the how what the big deal was
for veal there's not even that much
better just let it grow to the adult and
then you know eat that one this is
tender I hated by a pond
hope you guys enjoyed that video but if
you didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up hey